when she was only 16 years old Debbie
Reynolds entered the Miss Burbank beauty
contest not because she felt she had the
requisite confidence in her appearance
as she should have but because first
prize was a screen test and a sweater
well it shouldn't be too difficult to
guess which part of the prize intrigued
Debbie the most when she wanted that's
right the sweater the screen test also
went did very well for her and had an
enormous impact on her life beginning
with her featured roles in the daughter
of Rosie O'Grady and three little words
and two weeks with love it was at 19
years of age that she made the movie
that would define her career singing in
the rain and pursuit of that sweater
also signaled her profound passion to
preserve the iconic costumes that we
associate with Hollywood's golden age
Debbie went on to become as we know one
of the best loved stars of several
generations and she has been maintained
intensely personal relationship with her
fans she's always given the full measure
of her talent her Verve and her
seemingly limitless delight in
performing in performances that have
transported audiences for half a century
unbeknownst to many outside the business
has been her dedication to preserving
the achievements of its most highly
talented craftspeople the artists and
the artisans whose inventive imagination
have helped make certain films and
performances iconic over the course of
the last 50 years
Debbie built this collection this
astonishing collection thousands of
items innumerable props and posters over
20,000 photographs and more than 3,500
carefully preserved costumes some of the
irreplaceable pieces that were included
in her collection were the famous black
and white Ascot dress that Audrey
Hepburn wore in my fair lady designed by
Cecil Beaton Charlie Chaplin's bowler
hat Marilyn Monroe's flyaway pleated
halt her white dress from the 7-year
itch judy garland's pinafore and the
legendary ruby slippers from The Wizard
of Oz and the dirndl dress and the
guitar that Julie Julie Andrews wore and
played in the in The Sound of Music to
name just a few
while today the value of these pieces is
inestimable the worth they're worth in
the world was not always credited and
Debbie struggled and she sacrificed for
decades acquiring these items
undertaking the cost by herself
of storing and maintaining them this has
been a crusade for Debbie and today as
the as the Academy embarks on securing a
home a repository for the record of our
film heritage Debbie Reynolds
preservation fight must be recognized
and rewarded
it's because of her early and continuing
efforts that the Academy Museum will
house the beautiful actual tangible
evidence of the imagination of our most
gifted artists the work of many many
thousands of hands that make up the
history of design will be seen and
appreciated for all time for her
demonstration of devotion to the
entertainment industry that she has
loved and she has served all her life
and for her tireless efforts on behalf
of the faily UNS the mental health
center of Cedar sinai and UCLA's
operation mend as a mother as a
grandmother and as a preserver of
Hollywood's treasures I am truly proud
and deeply honored to present the
remarkable inimitable beautiful miss
Burbank Debbie Reynolds with the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award
and so sorry that I'm sick but I have
thrilled beyond words shocked and you
couldn't be more amazed that a little
girl from Burbank even came here this
sort of accolade anything I've ever done
is to their recognition for the audience
to always love the work and not just the
work that they do this was for mental
health you have to love love the cause I
have tried thank you feel wonderful news
god bless you I thank you very much
and as Debbie can't be with us tonight
her granddaughter Billie lourd is here
to accept this honor on her behalf
Billie
signing hi I'm Debbie's granddaughter
Billie I'm here to accept I'm here to
accept the award on her behalf cuz as
you know she sadly can't be here it
honestly feels super weird to be up here
without her cuz she's always been the
leader of our family whether it be it
award shows like this or at home I've
truly never seen him it I've never seen
her miss a show in her life but
unfortunately our leader needed a little
backup tonight so I'm here to thank the
Academy and all of you in this room for
this truly incredible honor I can't tell
you how excited she is about it I'll be
taking it home to her right now so we
can cuddle with it and she can put it in
the place she's always secretly saved
for it
I think it's next to the ruby slippers
we'll see thank you so much